what is an anti-universe you've heard
about it lately another universe
discovered where time goes backwards
where the laws of physics are completely
opposite of those that we cherish in our
own universe what does it all mean is it
just hype come along in this voyage into
the heart of reality and the meaning of
time and space itself
symmetries are some of the most
important aspects to physicists it's
been defined by frank wilcek and others
as change without change in other words
you perform some physical operation some
motion some movement perhaps and the
properties of what you're observing
don't change you're familiar with this
if you take a circle and rotate it by
any amount it stays circular if you take
a snowflake and rotate it by multiples
of 60 degrees it remains basically the
same shape those are symmetries under
rotation
there are many different types of
symmetries and courtesy of emmy noither
one of the greatest mathematicians of
all time
we know that for every underlying
symmetry in a physical law there's
something that's conserved we already
described two different things that are
conserved conservation of shape and
actually conservation under translation
in motion those are related to physical
phenomena that we manifest as
conservation of angular momentum in the
case of rotation in a case of motion and
symmetry without change as you move the
laws of physics of your laboratory don't
change
that's conservation of momentum
we also have conservation of energy
conservation of charge and other
esoteric abstract spaces like isospin
and there's even something called
supersymmetry which is even more
symmetric than ordinary symmetry but now
there's been a claim that one of the
laws of physics underpinned by symmetry
is leading some physicists to suspect
there might be a so-called anti-universe
a universe parallel to ours in a certain
sense wherein time goes backwards
a recent paper by latham boyle and neil
turrock and collaborators suggests that
there may be an so-called anti-universe
and it may explain some of the results
we spoke about with my friend and
colleague professor abigail vireg so i
always i'm an experimentalist which you
know and so i'll always i'll answer the
question about the data first what else
could it be background wise and then you
published the data at that time abby was
dubious about the claims made in the
most prestigious of all scientific
journals the journal known as the new
york post well the new york post is on
it again along with a host of other
venues all touting the so-called
anti-universe what does it mean what
does it mean for you should we be
anxious about another universe where
time flows backwards could that allow us
to go back in time oh this is heavy well
not quite but it does have a bearing on
that very favorite subject of ours on
this channel experimental particle
physics and neutrinos two great tastes
that go great together let's take a step
back
we talked about symmetry under rotation
and translation but there are three
other so-called discrete symmetries that
are of paramount importance to
physicists
the first one is so-called charge
invariance that the laws of physics
don't discriminate between a positive
and negative charge in fact if you
reverse the charges of the proton and
the electron a hydrogen atom would still
behave the same effectively as it does
now charge is absolute you put a
negative sign in front of the existing
charge and the laws of physics don't
change there's another phenomena closely
allied with charge conservation and
charge discrete symmetry inversion
called parity inversion that the laws of
physics should not depend on whether or
not you look at a phenomenon in the
mirror or not
and that can be manifestly observed if
you looked at say a pendulum swinging
back and forth in a mirror you couldn't
tell if you were looking at the pendulum
directly swinging or if you were looking
at a mirror image or reversed image
now this most recent result involves
time symmetry
so another way to think about time
reversal symmetry has to do with
so-called conservation of energy but if
you think about looking down from above
in a god's eye view perhaps of our solar
system the planets orbiting in one
direction that would be completely
indistinguishable if you were going
above the plane of the of the solar
system or if you're looking at it from
below and reverse the time direction
so the
motions of the planets don't seem to
depend upon our convention of what we
call time flowing positive and time
flowing negative and yet there is a
series of different arrows of time that
distinguish forward from backward but
when we think about time can it be
extracted from it a universal definition
in which time is somehow emerges from
the micro laws of physics well if it
does and those micro laws are
independent of the coordinate that we
call positive time versus negative time
then how should there be an arrow of
time
so time symmetry is closely connected to
conservation of energy and in this
current result it makes use of a
conjecture that was really a simplifying
trick it was one weird trick not to help
you lose weight not to help you gain
success in your business but instead
this was a trick that john arnold
wheeler we've talked about in reference
to the bright wheeler effect where
photons come together and create matter
they also conjectured that you could
interpret antimatter as the propagation
of ordinary matter backwards in time in
other words the antiparticle of the
electron is a positron
they conjectured that you could consider
a positron
traveling forward in time as an electron
traveling backwards in time and if you
think about current flowing through a
wire positive current if it's going this
way carried by electrons moving that way
if you reverse the direction of time you
could have positrons going this way and
the current would still be flowing in
that same direction so when we talk
about the anti-universe we could mean
many different things but typically when
scientists talk about it they mean
version of anti-matter so the
anti-matter for each fundamental
particle is called anti but there's
really only historical reasons why we
call it that similar to ben franklin
considering the electron to have a
negative charge versus a positive charge
when in fact the electrons are things
that are moving some say old ben should
have referred to electrons as having
positive charge
nevertheless when we talk about
antimatter we can think about inverting
either the charge
coordinate if you like changing all
positive charges and negative charges or
converting all time coordinates to
negative time coordinates or the
direction of time to its opposite and
the physics will be indistinguishable so
an explanation for why we see so much
more matter than antimatter in our
universe owes to some violation of the
symmetry which we know has to be there
in fact there were three conditions laid
out by the great soviet scientist andrei
sakharov they're known by the sacrifice
conditions they involve thermal
equilibrium violation of baryon number
and they also involve what's called cp
violation we talked about cp violation
we discussed what some of my twitter
followers claimed to be the most
important experiment of all time
matamu's christmas experiment in 1957
showed clearly that parity is not
conserved that you could distinguish the
mirror world from our ordinary world she
did so using spinning cobalt 60 nuclei
as we discussed the merit dimension
where i'm in control well cp violation
doesn't hold in our universe it's
violated at a weak level and that's one
of the saccharov conditions that lead to
what's called bariogenesis formation of
matter ordinary baryons like protons and
neutrons and my favorite the croutons
now if we could find a universe in which
there was more antimatter than matter
would we be able to detect it would be
able to distinguish it and then the
question of whether or not this universe
could be taken as not having opposite
charges but having an opposite time
coordinate that's the subject of this
paper this paper created so many
headlines back in 2018 that we had to
have on dr abby vireg who worked on the
anita project which seemed to suggest
according to the new york post that
there was a multiverse now the
multiverse has many different garbs as
we've talked about in our interviews
with folks such as paul steinhardt and
will kinney these discussions revolve
really on the fact that there's multiple
multiple universes there's the ever
ready and many worlds hypothesis
universe the claim now is that all
neutrinos that we observe are so-called
left-handed neutrinos left-handed
neutrinos are the only type of neutrinos
that we find in nature we also only find
right-handed so-called anti-neutrinos
now this new result that caused such a
fuss
suggested that if there was a so-called
sterile neutrino
that was right-handed not an
anti-neutrino that are all right-handed
but an actual non-anti-or ordinary
neutrino that was right-handed that
would interact not by any of the other
forces and fields that we know about in
nature but would only interact via
gravity and in that sense it could also
be seen as a sort of candidate for a
dark matter particle and as you know
we've talked about in previous videos
neutrinos of any type in this case
ordinary neutrinos are the only form of
dark matter we know exists dark matter
is characterized by its non-interaction
with ordinary matter it's not emission
or absorption of light
a sterile neutrino one that doesn't
interact with ordinary neutrinos is one
that could have mass and so because it
has mass it would interact only
gravitationally not with other weak
particles not with the strong force
obviously not with the electromagnetic
force or else it would give off light or
absorb light and wouldn't be dark so
this is a fascinating conjecture
now where does it leave us well it's one
type of multiverse okay it may be
another universe that predated r sort of
going backwards in time and then leading
to the initiation of our universe and
the ordinary big bang
it could be though that this is a sort
of a parallel universe as was originally
conjectured in the new york post article
at least
now the evidence for these sterile
neutrinos is marginal at best and
astronomers such as abby and her
colleagues are hard at work on upgrading
the types of experiments like the anita
experiment that's not the only way
though that we could exclude rule out or
falsify the claims of the so-called
anti-universe where time goes backwards
it could be that if we do discover there
is a single origin of time characterized
by excessively low entropy prior to the
formation of nuclei during the big bang
nucleosynthesis output that this epoch
of inflation
would produce an observable signal that
we hopefully would see the simon's
observatory and with the bicep array
experiment and other experiments that
are ongoing around the world and note
that it can't be seen in my opinion by
just one team
for us to have credibility after the
events that i've described previously on
this channel and in my book losing the
nobel prize we need to have multiple
confirmations of the signal before other
scientists in other fields ranging from
metaphysics to particle physics will
accept the credulity in our discovery of
primordial gravitational waves but if we
do detect gravitational waves that would
be strong circumstantial but still
strongest evidence to date that
inflation took place which would mean
that time behaves as we expected to in
an ordinary fashion that there was no
backwards flowing time at least in our
universe so we have many avenues of
experimental falsification
disconfirmation or confirmation that
could lead to a whole host of models
being accepted or refuted both this
backwards time flowing universe and even
refuting inflation if we can discover
some evidence potentially for a bouncing
cosmological model as we've talked about
now we'll have on co-author along with
paul steinhardt and aegis in an upcoming
video she is a world expert on the
bouncing cosmological models so stay
tuned for that and if you like videos
like this we talk about alternative
cosmologies and the multiverse i know
you're gonna love this playlist that
i've curated especially for you click
here and don't forget to subscribe